(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: WELCOME BACK, MY
GUEST TONIGHT ALSO KNOWN AS
AD-ROCK FROM THE LEGENDARY
BEASTIE BOYS CAN CURRENTLY BE
SEEN IN THE MOVIE "WHILE WE'RE
YOUNG."
>> HIS TASTE IS DEMOCRATIC,
IT'S "THE GOONIES" AND IT'S
"CITIZEN KANE". THEY DON'T
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
HIGH AND LOW. IT'S WONDERFUL.
>> WHEN DID "THE GOONIES"
BECOME A GOOD MOVIE?
>> WELL, YOU SHOULD HEAR THIS
GUY TALK ABOUT IT.
>> AND IT IS LIKE THEIR
APARTMENT IS FULL OF
EVERYTHING WE ONCE THREW OUT BUT
IT LOOKS SO GOOD THE
WAY THEY HAVE IT.
>> WHO DIRECTED "THE
GOONIES?"
I'LL LOOK IT UP.
>> WHY IS IT THAT WHEN ONE
PERSON PICKS UP THEIR PHONE,
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TO.
>> I JUST HAVE A QUICK THING.
>> I'M NOT ON MY PHONE.
>> THE BABY.
>> RICHARD DONNER.
>> EACH OF US IS SO CERTAIN
WE HAVE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING TO DO RIGHT NOW.
>> I KNOW, IT'S SO RUDE.
>> NOT ANY MORE.
IT USED TO BE BUT NOW IT'S
ACCEPTED.
ITS LIKE SHOWING YOUR ANKLES
IN THE 1800S.
>> Jon: PLEASE WELCOME ADAM
HOROVITZ.
COME AND SIT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
DO A SHOW. DO A SHOW. SIT!
FIRST OF ALL,
CONGRATULATIONS-- TO OUR NEW
YORK-- REALLY?
DID YOU REALLY --
>> OH, NO, JUST, IT'S
NICE TO BE HERE.
>> Jon: THAT WAS -- I REALLY
THOUGHT YOU POPPED A DISC.
>> NO, JUST RELAXING.
>> Jon: BEAUTIFUL, RELAX AN
ENJOY. SIT THERE.
>> I MEAN I'M NOT GOING TO
-- THIS IS THE TIME I AM
I'M GOING TO
BE ON THE SHOW.
>> Jon: RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M JUST -- WELL YEAH, RIGHT
NOW.
>> Jon: THIS IS AMAZING.
>> I'M JUST SAYING I'M ON YOUR
SHOW.
>> Jon: YOU'RE ON IT RIGHT
NOW.
>> IT DOESN'T HAPPEN TO
EVERYBODY AND HERE I AM.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
TAKING IT IN.
>> Jon: SOAK IT IN. SOAK IT IN.
>> CAN I SIT THERE? JUST FOR A
SECOND.
>> Jon: I WOULD BE DELIGHTED
IF YOU WOULD SIT THERE.
PLEASE.
CAN I GET YOU -- HERE LET ME
GIVE YOU A MIC PACK.
CAN I GET YOU A SNACK?
>> WHAT'S GOING ON HERE? NO, NO,
NO.
I JUST WANTED TO SEE.
>> Jon: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> SO, WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT
THE THING WHEN IT HAPPENED?
>> Jon: LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING.
>> WEIRD, RIGHT?
>> Jon: YOU KNOW WHAT, LET
ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
>> POLITICS AND STUFF, AND
JOKES.
I'M BACK, I'M BACK.
>> Jon: POLITICS AND STUFF
AND JOKES.
>> FUNNY ONES.
>> Jon: IT'S JUST HARD, YOU
SUMMED ME UP.
IT TOOK YOU THREE SECONDS.
>> AND NOW, AND NOW YOU'RE GONE.
AND THAT'S IT.
>> Jon: LET ME ASK YOU A
QUESTION.
>> TELL ME.
>> Jon: DID YOU REALLY SEE
MY MOVIE?
>> NO.
>> I DON'T LIKE YOUR MOVIES.
>> Jon: SON OF A BITCH.
>> YEAH, I'M SORRY.
>> Jon: NO, I MEANT YOU.
>> YES, I KNOW.
>> Jon: I'M BEING YOU, I'M
YOU, YOU'RE ME.
>> I DON'T WANT TO.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT. LET'S DO
THIS.
LET'S GO STITCH IT AROUND.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS SAD?
>> HUH?
>> Jon: PHYSICALLY, WE COULD
PULL THIS OFF.
>> YEAH? ARE WE RELATED?
WE'RE COUSINS. HUH, LOOK AT
THIS.
>> Jon: GIVE ME A FACE IN HERE,
GET A LITTLE CLOSE.
>> WHAT WAS THAT? DID YOU JUST
GET --
>> AT SOME POINT.
>> I DIDN'T SEE THE LOOK IN YOUR
EYE.
>> Jon: IN A BIBLICAL LAND.
>> IS THIS MINE?
>> Jon: MY GREAT GREAT GREAT
GREAT GRANDFATHER AND YOUR GREAT
GREAT GREAT GREAT
GRANDFATHER WHATEVER, SAID
I'M GOING TO GO THIS WAY,
YOU GO THAT WAY.
>> WHATEVER.
>> Jon: HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M GREAT.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, I LOVE
YOU. AND I DON'T -- WE'VE --
>> I LIKE YOU, A LOT.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: REALLY, NOT? I MEAN --
>> I DON'T KNOW YOU, I MEAN, YOU
KNOW.
>> Jon: WE'VE NEVER MET.
>> YOU'RE FUNNY AND YOU
TELL THE STUFF ON THE SHOW.
>> Jon: I KNOW.
>> Jon: DO YOU STILL GO-- DO
YOU STILL ENJOY GOING TO THE
RECORD STORES AND GOING IN
AND BROWSING.
>> NO, I DON'T. I DON'T.
IT'S MORE OF-- IT'S TOO
DEEP.
IT'S TOO MUCH.
I CAN'T DO IT RIGHT NOW.
>> Jon: TOO DEEP AND TOO
MUCH IN TERMS OF?
>> I DON'T, YOU KNOW, I HAVE
THOUSANDS OF RECORDS FROM
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS
AND THOUSANDS OF 45s AND I
DON'T LISTEN TO THEM.
>> Jon: RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> ENOUGH, I DON'T SPEND
ENOUGH TIME WITH THEM SO
THEY WILL BE UPSET IF I'M
GOING TO GET MORE FRIENDS.
I'M JUST-- YOU ASKED ME A
QUESTION.
AND I'M ANSWERING AS ME.
>> Jon: LET ME ASK YOU A
QUESTION, I MEAN THIS
SINCERELY.
>> YEAH.
WHICH RECORD DO YOU THINK
WOULD BE THE MADDEST?
(LAUGHTER)
>> OH, METERS "CABBAGE ALLEY,"
DEFINITELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
I SPENT SO LONG TRYING TO
FIND IT.
AND THEN I HAD A MOMENT,
LIKE A BEAUTIFUL MOMENT
LAYING ON A FLOOR IN A
RECORD STORE IN PITTSBURGH.
>> Jon: OH, NO.
>> YES, LYING ON THE FLOOR,
FLIPPING THROUGH THE ONES
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE OUT,
THEY HAVE THEM ON THE
BOTTOM.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND IT WAS CABBAGE ALLEY,
CABBAGE ALLEY, CABBAGE ALLEY.
>> Jon: AND YOU FOUND IT.
>> AND I HAVE IT.
>> Jon: WHEN DID YOU FIND
IT.
>> 20 YEARS AGO.
>> Jon: AND AT THAT TIME IT WAS
THE HOLY GRAIL.
>> IT WAS ONE OF THEM, YEAH.
>> Jon: ARE STILL WRITING
MUSIC?
ARE YOU STILL WRITING -- WHAT A
CREATIVE
OUTLET FOR YOU.
AND NOW OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW,
IT IS NOT THE SAME, BUT DO YOU
FILL STILL A WAY TO EXPRESS
YOURSELF THROUGH THAT?
>> MUSICALLY?
>> Jon: YES.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
I PLAY IN A BAND WITH MY
FRIEND BRIDGET EVERETT.
>> Jon: OH VERY NICE.
>> AND WE'RE CALLED BRIDGET
EVERETT AND THE TENDER MOMENTS.
I'M A TENDER MOMENT.
>> Jon: AWW REALLY?
YOU ARE A TENDER MOMENT.
>> Jon: YOU REALIZE WHAT THIS
IS.
SO, LET ME TELL YOU WHAT
THIS IS.
>> WHERE AM I LOOKING, HERE?
>> Jon: YOU CAN LOOK THERE.
SO YOU ARE, IF I MAY SAY,
ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PERFORMERS OF ALL TIME.
AND I NEVER WOULD GET A
CHANCE TO HANG OUT WITH YOU.
SO THE INTERVIEW, WE'RE
HAVING A TENDER MOMENT BUT
THE INTERVIEW ENDED LIKE TEN
MINUTES AGO.
SO THIS IS ALL ME KEEPING
YOU HERE LONGER THAN
YOU'RE-- BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW THAT I WILL EVER GET
THIS CHANCE AGAIN.
AND SO THIS IS EXCITING.
(APPLAUSE)
>> WHY ARE WE DOING THIS NOW?
AND WE DIDN'T DO THIS A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO?
>> Jon: YOU DON'T ANSWER MY
CALLS.
BUT I WOULD-- I WOULD DO THAT --
>> I NEED A NEW
PHONE TOO, IF YOU COULD TALK
TO THE PEOPLE ABOUT THE
LAPTOP AND THE THING.
>> Jon: I'M GOING TO GET YOU
A PHONE, A LAPTOP AND AN
ALBUM THAT YOU'VE NEVER
HEARD OF.
>> OKAY.
WHAT DO WANT?
WHAT CAN I GET FOR YOU?
>> Jon: STOP IT, NOTHING.
>> NO REALLY.
>> Jon: CAN I TELL YOU,
YOU'VE GOTTEN IT FOR ME.
JUST YOUR TIME WAS ENOUGH. IT
WAS ENOUGH.
IT WAS ENOUGH.
YOU.
>> YOU'RE A CLASS ACT.
>> Jon: YOU, YOU'RE A CLASS ACT.
>> Jon: ALSO HE'S IN SOME
[BLEEP] A MOVIE.
IT'S IN THE THEATRES NOW,
ADAM HOROVITZ.